of course vortex manipulator one of the
few props I don't actually have so folks
this is gonna be the inaugural episode
of what will be an occasional sort of
sub series when I talk about Doctor Who
which is going to be Doctor Who dangling
plot threads or at least dangling at the
time that I record them because given
the nature of Doctor Who any of these
can be picked up at any time so there
are a number of things that I was
considering talking about I toss them
out to the folks over on my patreon get
that plug in there
help me yeah and they selected out of
the options I gave them for me to today
talk about the time agency now when I
talk about this and also in the future
when I talk about dangling plot threads
I'm going to be focusing on the show's
because I know that talking about this
or if I ever talk about things like
Jenny the doctor's daughter or new
paradigm Daleks or anything else I'd be
I would consider to be dangling plot
thread that many if not all of these
have been picked up and expanded on in
novels comics audio etc I'm not counting
any of that not because I don't think
it's good or doesn't deserve attention
or anything like that but because the
simple truth is the Canon is the show
and while the books comics audio etc do
try to fit within the Canon of the show
that courtesy doesn't extend the same
way the show does not and won't care if
it does something that contradicts
something that was in an audio before
it's gonna do its own thing to the point
that they've taken some of the audio
stories and adapted them directly and
same with some of the novels so the the
respect for canon only goes in one
direction so keeping that in mind and
keep in mind that I am aware this stuff
has been expanded on in extra media but
I'm not talking about that what is the
time agency what do we know about it
within the context
the show when was it introduced what
could be done with it that isn't being
done with it so stick with me I'm gonna
say something that some folks are gonna
be like wait I'll get that so the time
agency was effectively introduced when
we met Captain Jack Harkness who was a
rogue time agent he was a former time
agent now working as a con man
technically the idea of time agents was
dropped prior to that but that's the
thing I will come back to so just stick
with me here so what we learned at that
time was not a lot we sort of we knew
you know they used the vortex
manipulators to get around we know that
the time agency wiped two years from
Jack's memory he to the best of my
knowledge at least in the show's if it
came up in the other stuff I don't know
but as far as the shows go which is the
cannon he never found out what that two
years was he never got it back but
realizing that they did that to him is
what caused him to leave and basically
go out and do his own thing the extent
to which the time agency has come up
since then has been very limited and
very off handed within Torchwood we had
the introduction of Captain John Hart
who also was a former time agent
actually was Jack's partner for a time
and we have had references to time
agents usually as an explanation for
where somebody got a vortex manipulator
from so we know where that they are the
source of those things and more to the
point they seem to be really bad at
keeping track of them because they're
rogue agents have them and people like
like what was his name crass go has it
and River Song is her hands on one like
they seem oddly easy to get ahold of for
an agency that by its name you would
think is trying to police time-travel
and that's sort of the next thing what
is the time agency well exactly what is
a little bit fuzzy because we've never
actually seen it in the show one would
guess and this I do know enough to know
this is supported by the supplementary
material that it sort of came about one
that
Time Lords vanished basically nobody was
monitoring or keeping track of what the
effects of time travel was having on the
world as a whole somebody had to fill
the vacuum so it was the time agency now
part of the reason I found myself
thinking about this is because I watch
legends of tomorrow and there is a I
think it's the time Bureau in that I
found myself watching that going is this
basically what the time agency would
have been like on Doctor Who if we ever
got to see it and that's kind of my
default headcanon it's a group that is
monitoring doing their best probably in
a little over their heads could be doing
it better but there's nobody else doing
it right now now some folks might point
out that well there's nowhere to go with
this because in his appearance in the
series to opener for Torchwood John Hart
says that the time agency has been
disbanded well a couple things about
that the first is the entire rest of
that episode basically demonstrates why
we can and should never ever ever trust
anything this guy says so the
information he gives on that is
immediately suspect and shouldn't be
taken at face value but even if he's
telling the truth that leaves its own
dangling plot thread because what he
says is it was disbanded there was
basically seven of us meaning seven
other time agents left so that's still a
dangling plot thread because if
somebody's dismayed and what do you mean
there's seven time agents left there are
seven people left who were part of it
but now they're doing whatever are there
seven people acting as independent
contractors with no longer a central
governing authority because the time
agency is gone that's still somebody
that could be picked on and and worked
with now it's also worth pointing out
that even if the time agency is
quote-unquote gone that doesn't mean
anything because they travel through
time so they even if like say in the
65th century they were disbanded doesn't
matter because the version of the agency
from the 58th century can still travel
to a way later point in time so we could
still run into them there's no reason
for them not to show up now I mentioned
that the time agency has actually gotten
to mentioned prior to this and this is
also again one of the things that got
expanded on further in supplementary
materials but technically the first
mention of the time agency is from
a classic Doctor Who story a Fourth
Doctor story called the talents of Wang
Qiang now in that the villain mistakes
the doctor for a time agent now that's
kind of all we get from that story my
presumption based off the context of
that wasn't at the time agency was a
completely different thing but that it
was like something within Gallifrey
society like Time Lords time agents all
sort of under the umbrella of Gallifrey
whether or not that was intended to be
the case doesn't really matter because
it was so loose then that they could
mold it into whatever they were gonna
have it be later but that doesn't reduce
the idea that the time agency was if not
around at an earlier point at the very
least because of time-travel shenanigans
mucking around with stuff well ahead of
when we met Captain Jack Harkness so
again that opens up the possibility of
injecting them into stuff aware there's
really no reason that they couldn't be
so the question becomes why haven't they
done anything with this which does
strike me as a little bit odd I suppose
there's probably a couple reasons the
first is part of what keeps dr. who
follow Abel is because even as we are
jumping all over points of time and
everything else we are sticking with the
doctor and we are consonant with the
doctor on the doctors own chronology you
start introducing other time travelers
into that who are on their own separate
canal chronology and things get
complicated fairly quickly I mean we've
already seen what can happen with that
with a River Song whether you love her
or hate her or love the way that her
story was done or don't like the way
your story was done you can't deny it
was complicated and trying to take an
agency of theoretically multiple people
and weave it into the story in a similar
manner to how River Song was yeah that's
gonna get messy quickly but only if they
try to make them like a thing like a
regularly appearing thing and there's no
need to do that but I think it would be
interesting if every now and then if the
- ran into a time agent who basically
considers the doctor to be a menace -
considers the doctor to be an amateur
because he's not answering to anybody
and he doesn't have the bureaucratic
structure behind him or that the doctor
gets annoyed with him it's like I've
been doing this a lot longer than you
back off I kind of love to see the the
head-butting that would happen if the if
a time agents crossed with the doctor
and they were both trying to deal with
the same thing and maybe they disagreed
as to what the resolution should be or
something like that
again I'm not sure should necessarily be
an ongoing thing but like there's a lot
of meat to be mined off that I'm mixing
my metaphors here but you know just as a
one-off you could totally do that and
not to mention like I said that's a
pretty big dangling thread with never
having found out what Jax - your gap was
about at this point I would not expect
that to ever get addressed in the show
because I don't expect Jack to come back
at this point he was gone for the
entirety of of Elevens run and 12 and
now we're in 213 like it's not
impossible there's no reason he can't
come back but I'm not holding my breath
for it at this point and unless they do
there's no reason to address that now if
they ever do bring Captain Jack back I
would like to see that address cuz it
was set up like from his very first
appearance yet and it really felt like
it was being set up as something to be
addressed later and never was then again
part of me wonders if at this point
since it's been so long since that got
introduced is there anything that the
answer could be that wouldn't come off
as a bit of an anti-climax a bit of a
disappointment I don't know it's just
interesting to me that the time agency
feels like it's a toy in the toy box
that nobody's touching and everybody's
choosing to work around but it's there
it's right there and like especially
with something like because they
introduced the shadow Proclamation in
series 4 it might have gotten to mention
earlier but we actually saw them in
series 4 and I found them deeply
underwhelming I'm like you are boring
generic and what are you here like why
couldn't that have been the time agency
something we had heard of since series 1
of this show coming back
something that had an origin of sorts in
the classic era as opposed to this weird
albino lady and her hired Rhino goons
like that's okay I would have I think it
would have fit much better to have that
have been the time agency or any other
time that just an authority has come up
I mean we've seen the storm cages does
the time agency run those it would make
sense but we've never really had a
confirmation with that there's a slight
connection and that you know people who
have showed up later with their hands on
vortex manipulator manipulators have
spent time and time cages but again the
actual connection has never been made
explicit and normally I make the
complaint that you can't you with a show
like Doctor Who you shouldn't be
bringing back the same stuff too much
because it makes the universe seem small
like it at a point it's very weird that
the doctor keeps running into the same
people over and over and over again or
like how I don't like how the doctor has
a myth like across the universe because
he saved so many you know so many
planets I'm like I'm sorry I don't care
how many planets he's solved there's he
saved there's an infinite number of them
not as many should be aware of him so
I've made that complaint before but with
the time agency I think there's a bit
more wiggle room because since it moves
about in time the same way that the
doctor does it makes sense for them to
pop up in more places in a way that
doesn't make sense for characters who
are stuck on a singular timeline to keep
turning up over and over and over again
so I just think it would be really
interesting to see what somebody could
do with this and like I said don't build
up they not of it don't make like a
series arc out of it but have it in them
for a bit of fun because I think there's
potential there and again my notion of
the time agency is more on the fun side
again because I've kind of projected the
legends of tomorrow time agency into
this and that's fun but that's my hope
that's a dangling plot thread that a
kind of which somebody would pull on do
something with what are your thoughts
about the time agency what are all the
stuff going on in the supplementary
material that I don't know about it
you're gonna completely lay out for me
whatever you want to tell me drop it
down in the comments let's talk about it
there's stuff to do if you want to
support me help
pay my bills I've got a patron there's
also the subscribe but I click has been
a big help lately you folks have been
hitting it and I do appreciate it bunch
of other stuff to do down there besides
but you don't have to do it if you don't
want to at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]